- If I was nobody which is
99 percent of people now.
I don't have a million followers.
I'm trying to grow.
I'm trying to build my
dreams and aspirations.
I'm literally doing what I just showed you
for 10 hours a day.
The reason we're sitting here today
is I decided from 2007
to 2011 to spend four
to eight hours a day replying
to people on Twitter.
That weren't even talking to me.
You could type in the name of that town
and then go in Instagram
and then go to places,
click it and see every photo
that's be posted in your town.
In that town.
You could then go look at the photo.
It could be her at a
Goodwill saying huge score.
You could reply and say good shit.
Seven to 150 on a fucking stapler?
Go girl!
Now all of a sudden,
she's just a normal human.
She only gets six comments to begin with.
She's like who's this man?
She clicks, she goes.
Your bio is I sell homes.
She's like "Cool, nice guy.
"Hope he's not weird" and she's out.
But the 97th person that does that
goes "He seems nice."
Goes in the funnel.
You put out a good piece of content, like
"I'm gonna DM him.
"I'm thinking about selling my home."
What people don't understand
is how much work I put
to even begin the process
of who I am today.
2007, 2011's a long time
ago for a lot of people.
That year I decided to
go on Twitter search.
And anybody that talked about wine,
I jumped in and talked to them.
How did I get here?
Hand to hand combat.
Give me your phone.
Let me show you something.
So you go to Columbia, Maryland.
You go to places, right?
So I'm in, into the search.
This is gonna work for all
of you if you want to build.
So you just go to Columbia, Maryland.
And right now it's gonna
show you all the top photos
and all the recent photos.
What I did, but on Twitter
with the word pinot noir
is I literally, and look,
Instagram's a little bit of a different.
Like the first photo is like a dude
who's looking real diesel and shit.
And so I mean you could, you
could, and I'm not joking.
I would literally go in
here and be like "Swoll".
- [Group] Right.
- Post.
I did it.
(group laughing)
- [Woman] He's like I
didn't wanna say that!
- [Man] I don't care.
- But this is, look,
there's a couple good
things going for you.
One, your name is Realtor Brian.
The fact, this is how I think, right?
I think.
- [Brian] I was gonna
ask you about that too.
Is my name good?
- I think, it is good
And again, look.
What's gonna be unpopular?
Attractive people.
So as a guy it's a pretty girl,
you don't wanna come across creepy.
You gotta be thoughtful.
You don't have to go to every post.
But you go to these posts, right?
And this is happening.
These posts are happening
in this town, right?
For example, here's something about
- Wegmans
- She works Wegmans, right?
Literally you're like "Love that"
and I'm doing it right for you right now
because I don't think
people get it, right?
"Love that place."
Right?
So I want you to become
the mayor of the town.
I did what I just showed
you for four hours,
five hours, six hours a day on Twitter.
If I was nobody which is
99 percent of people now.
I don't have a million followers.
I'm trying to grow.
I'm trying to build my
dreams and aspirations.
I'm literally doing what I just showed you
for 10 hours a day, six hours a day.
- This is your dollar 80, right?
- It's my dollar 80.
Right?
Leaving your two cents 90 times a day.
Dollar 80.
When you're local, you're set.
You have to say most people don't get
4000 comments like I do.
They get seven.
And they're pumped when
they get a new one.
Right?
I can see by all your body languages.
I know what the masses are living.
So now you're getting attention.
Now notice what I did.
I didn't just say cool or a heart.
I looked at the picture.
And it was a swoll dude, swoll.
Like Wegmans, I like that place.
Or you could have said
something about the oranges.
The most you give an actual comment.
- [Woman] In real context.
- The more you'll
actually get what you want
which is awareness with the hope
that it leads to something you want.
I remember it like yesterday,
just sitting there.
It's like 1:47 and you know
you gotta wake up soon.
And you're just saying
"With the pinot grigio!"
Or like "Drink it next year!"
Or like "Did you ever try this?"
And you're sitting there and
you're like is this worth it?
I knew it was but if I
even thought about it,
like if it even crossed my mind once
I know that's what's top
of mind to everybody else.
What I just said is right.
Very clearly articulated.
90 percent are gonna be
like that makes sense,
one percent's gonna execute.
40 percent's gonna start.
But they're gonna give up within 48 hours,
within 13 days, within four months.
And if I did four years in
I wouldn't be sitting here.
Hey guys thank you so much for
watching my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project
for me and I have a funny
feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all
or know anybody that drinks wine at all
please go to empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription.
Whether it's a three pack,
whether it's a six pack
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year,
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me
and I could really use your support.
(light upbeat music)